good morning bachelor nation who has
slept who has not I got a little bit and
this man is here to talk about last
night's Bachelorette finale round of
applause for Colton Underwood yes oh my
gosh everybody I'm Lauren Zima
of course this is roses and Rose a live
and we are fresh off of a Bachelorette
finale the live after the final rose and
tonight we have the bachelor in paradise
premiere so Colton we are gonna dive
into everything I'm sure you guys have
questions and comments for Colton leave
them on our social media channels right
now and we will get them here on the
iPad and get into it and Colton you have
dressed for paradise I love this jacket
colorful flowers but yet you know still
out there still out there it's I like it
cuz it's a little bit like you might
from afar think it's a rose so you're
both hitting on the finale and on
Paradise which we're gonna do today all
right so let's dive in to Bachelorette
finale because again we're fresh off
this and by the way you guys et of
course spoke with Becca and Garrett this
morning in New York I could not fly out
for that interview but of course I
submitted my questions to be asked and
we are gonna have those interviews up
for you detailing come in tonight and
Entertainment Tonight where we asked
Becca and Garrett some questions that
maybe they didn't get asked last night
you watch the finale I'm sure yes
sometimes people in bachelor nation
watch together did you watch it with
anybody where were you last night no I
was in my hotel room here I just got off
a plane from New York so team no sleep
I'm right there with you okay he caught
up with it your initial takeaway as you
watch all three hours of it what was
your big takeaway from the night you
know the fact that Becca was so torn
even all the way up until the moment I
think being on the season and seeing it
in a different way and sort of the
behind the scenes stuff is you know you
always saw the connection with Blake and
then slowly you did see that connection
with Garrett you know develop and all at
the same time I'm trying to work on my
connection so it's it's like it's an
interesting take but I would say I just
like what Becca said but we thought we
all thought Blake was the front-runner
the whole entire time that's how you
guys felt in the house yeah yeah cuz it
was wild when she was saying and I felt
some of those things she said felt
so real that she was saying you were so
solid from day one you know Blake got
the first one-on-one when she was on the
set of and that she almost felt guilty
having feelings for other people because
she felt so solid about Blake did you
guys get that sense I mean was it that
you felt she was holding back with you
and thinking maybe it was because of her
connection with Blake you know when she
said that it resonated with me it was
like that makes a lot of sense because
there was times on group dates where if
Blake was there you could tell it was a
different flow of a conversation just
because you know if whether you I
remember in Vegas I went after Blake and
I didn't get the same energy that I
typically get so Becca Becca right after
Blake go after him but you went after a
few people in mental yeah no I didn't go
after but I went I went and had a
conversation back after Blake and you
could tell like you know she you know
her level with with Blake was just above
everybody else's at that point
interesting so I did get a little bit
confused last night because Beca all
season long has said you know she wanted
a teammate she wanted somebody 50/50 and
she kind of said that about both guys I
don't know there was a lot of talk about
how Blake would be a perfect teammate
for her but then with Garrett she said
we're 50/50 what do you think teammate
meant to Becca what was she really
looking for I think she's looking for
somebody that matches her goofiness her
silliness and watching that back now to
it's like that makes so much sense I
think that was Garrett's edge that
silliness cuz we didn't really see Blake
be too silly but somebody see
Garrett's edge was just Garrett was so
authentic the whole entire season he had
no clue what he was getting himself into
he really didn't he didn't know what the
first impression Rose was and that's
what makes Garrett so corny and goofy
special and that's what makes you know
him the total package Rebecca and
watching that back it just it was one of
those aha okay like now this all makes
sense
interesting so how did Garrett end up on
the show sometimes his brother his
brother submitted him and he I don't
think he even committed to doing until
like the week before wow so he had not
been a viewer no interesting here didn't
know what the first impression Rose was
and then he got it okay comments coming
in Skye from YouTube wants to know who
did you like the most on The
Bachelorette who were you closest with
from the show my he's new Skye Skye my
I can be a guy's guy what is up my
friends on the show that I keep in
contact the most are Jason and Garrett
so those two guys I just grew really
close with the whole entire season from
day one so obviously last night during
the after the final rose we we had heard
a statement from Garrett about all this
Instagram stuff eat different memes that
he liked on Instagram but we heard him
speak about it live for the first time
kind of in his own words out loud what
were you doing is his friend behind the
scenes as all this was happening as it
was coming out were you having talks
with him and how was he feeling yeah I
think the the role that I wanted to play
for him as I knew that Becka couldn't
defend him publicly Becka couldn't even
be there to support like her guy because
that went by the weight yeah you can't
you can't spoil anything so just making
sure you know he was in a good mental
headspace and I'm not justifying
anything he did her like he even
admitted to me is like this is a growing
experience for me he's like I don't I
didn't expect this type of reaction he
really didn't know what he was getting
himself into and I think this is a good
learning lesson for all the young adults
and kids out there of what you do today
is gonna have an impression on your life
in five 10 15 years what you put out
what you put your digital fingerprint on
is gonna follow you your whole life and
it's not right and it's it's not it's
not something that I'm here to justify
but I also it's it's a mistake right you
live and you learn that's life
so he should not be crucified I feel I
feel like we've made the point he's made
his statement and we should move on and
celebrate Garrett and Becka
well one question I do still haven't as
his friend I guess I just want your
insight on this because the stuff that
he did like some people found offensive
and it seemed like what Garrett kept
saying was well I didn't know how much
power a double tap had I mean what do
you feel about his feelings on some of
these things he was liking memes where
people were saying that school shooting
victims are crisis actors some
anti-transgender stuff I think I think a
lot of people read too much into you you
DoubleTap something and you're attaching
feelings to that I think there's also a
way when you scroll through that and
this is not me defending but I know for
me sometimes I'm you know I'm walking in
the airport and I go quick DoubleTap
that's why subconsciously just we rent
we I randomly do that I don't think the
meaning in the feelings were behind the
dub
taps for so is Garrett the kind of guy
who because Becca is you know she's a
very independent woman we've talked
about this she's really strong is he the
kind of guy to support a strong
independent equal woman in a
relationship yeah and I think that's why
that relationship works so well is
because he's learning so much about
himself and of her and he respects her
in her view so much that he's willing to
grow and get out of his comfort zone or
get out of some of his maybe where his
head was at before and continue to grow
and get better as a person was that hard
for him I would imagine it had to be
difficult to be going through this
critique but not being able to say I'm
sure it was but Garrett is an athlete
too and that was one thing he was good
at he's like oh yeah you know I I know
it's hard I'm growing and sort of gave
me the athlete run around you know
they're like oh everything's okay I'm
fine I'm gonna do well you could tell I
was bugging him because you know he's at
a moment of his life right now where he
should be the happiest and he's having
to deal with the controversy and having
to deal with us what kind of things do
you think Becca is teaching him in their
relationship Oh everything a lot I mean
and it's the other way around I'm sure
Garrett is teaching Becca a lot of
things too and that's what a
relationship supposed to be like you
know you're always supposed to be
challenging you're always supposed to be
pushing your partner interesting do you
think that Blake does have cuz again
like I said that's what I wonder does
Garrett have this silly side because
Becca even said back with Arie she was
like I love what a goofball he is we
could tell she was looking for a good
girl does Blake have a sillier side that
we maybe didn't see did you know Blake
well he does yeah Blake does um the only
reason I know Gary and Jason will be
more is because Blake was so emotionally
invested news relationship and he kept
to himself really and it mentally in his
head yeah which is okay I mean that's
why you that's why you go on the show
but I was one of those that I was being
very realistic about this and this is
life if I'm if I'm here I'm gonna get
the full experience I'm gonna develop a
friendship with these guys if I have to
live with you and be in a house and date
the same girl is you don't want to get
to know you a little bit and I didn't
get that deep and on that level of Blake
but he's somebody who could tell who
goes all-in when he loves somebody and I
could respect that who was Blake close
in the house Becca
so sometimes people do like yeah they go
in there and they really are just
focused on the relationship yeah okay so
Blake was focused what do you think do
you think Blake's gonna be a bachelor
you know I think there's a lot of or are
you gonna be
there's a lot of good candidates for
Bachelor out there I really do
I think everybody's so deserving of love
and we're all gonna find it eventually
and whatever ABC decides to doing is
what they're gonna do okay
there's there's some good guys from the
series more questions coming Laura from
YouTube just says got to give props to
the guy in the jet she loves that you
wearing this jacket who is that
Laura Thank You Laura so much I
appreciate it did we not get to see well
you know what you wore Colton you were a
lot of hoodies I noticed it was a lot of
like a little hoodie moment I mean
that's it's an athlete now we're seeing
is different that's like stylish side of
you it meant all you were rocking like a
Paisley printer in your suit are you
more of a fashion risk risk-taker than
we knew I am yes and one thing I don't
like collars with my neck I just I don't
wear a lot of color so I love the
t-shirt underneath the suit jacket look
that is your look that is sort of my
thing
I hey it's good to have a thing Courtney
on YouTube wants to know so you've
experienced Bachelorette and bachelor in
paradise now how would you describe the
similarities and the differences
paradise premieres tonight on ABC you
guys what are the similarities and
differences for you and which did you
like more
so Courtney I would say they are so
different but I knew that going in I was
expecting a little different you know
they both were great experiences and
experiences on their own but I would say
I had a lot of fun on the Bachelorette
Season I really did and then bachelor in
paradise it was a little it was a little
more out of my comfort zone but it was
just the the environment that you know
being constantly surrounded by
relationships and constantly everybody's
hooking up everybody's making out well
no it's not even that it's just you
you're you watching other relationships
grow right in front of you and while
you're trying to focus on your own so
you're like you're trying to compare
yourself you know it's like well why
aren't we there yet or what am I doing
wrong not to be in a relationship like
them but I'm not sure you compare like
her connection with the other guys you
don't get to see it rain from your face
you don't you don't see in your face and
that's the difference so when you're
talking about that Colton do you mean
that Tia was having relationships with
other people right in front of you and
that was difficult I mean there was a
lot of people having a lot of
relationships in Paradise and tonight
you're gonna get a lot of answers that
you don't have answers to I think the
Bachelorette left a lot of questions for
fans in regards to the whole Tia Colton
story and that plays out in Paradise
we have seen you in the trailer Colton I
mean you are in tears you say that you
didn't think you'd be affected this much
what are you referring to there give us
a little hint of what's to come yeah I
think it brought up a lot of emotions
and good bad happy sad obviously a lot
of crying is it a lot of grind yourself
there's there's a lot of Tears involved
and I have never really experienced that
before I mean I wouldn't consider myself
a big emotional crier but a lot of
things you know took place in Paradise
that was very self discovering of myself
interesting okay did you and Tia
actually I think Tia told me you would
not you did not really speak between
Bachelorette and Paradise
we didn't so there's a lot of tension
going down on that beaches you're
walking down and it's like I feel like
she had at the time I feel like she had
something to do with my relationship
with Becca breaking up with me and at
the same time it's like well then why
didn't you reach out you know why are we
not like what I'm not reached out to you
like what it was sort of a stubborn game
right it's I'm not reaching out to you
if you're not reaching out to me one of
those things so a lot of tension built
up over that time and you'll see we're
like having a standoff yeah we sort of
just you know don't who don't cross this
line okay so on paradise we're gonna see
the line get crossed Heidi wants to know
what do you think was so unique about
Becca
compared to other bachelorettes I have
to say especially watching the finale
and seeing how much Garrett cried I mean
they both just seemed like they fell so
hard for her what do you think was
unique about Becca was it that she's
just so she's awful yes authentic and
she's goofy that's that's the other
thing is when you're around her the
cameras go away and the experience of
itself sort of fades
she's just so caught up she's so
engaging and when she asked away and
when she asked you a question she
genuinely wants the answer and you don't
feel that way a lot of times especially
nowadays you know people have their
phones out or they're just asking you
know a question to contribute to the
conversation just for the sake of the
conversation but for her she wanted to
know this answer she was very engaging
and very very good at you know being
herself okay um
Cyrene is just saying that you're a
sweetheart and a cutie hey thank you sir
I'm sorry and how are you jessica is
wandering Colton what was your favorite
date with Beckett what was your favorite
experience my favorite 101
I loved the [ __ ] date I really did
everybody's like oh that's sort of weird
a lot of puns on that day you know we
had a blast
and I grew up scuba diving snorkeling
and being in the water so was right up
my alley right up her alley she
Minnesota with all the lakes so we just
had a good day in the water on the on
the boat and you know it was fun
well Colton I want to ask you and I mean
again there has been some discussion
could Colton be the bachelor could wills
be the bachelor Jason Blake those names
have been thrown out there and by the
way a DJ online.com Chris Harrison
breaks down for us literally every
possible bachelor candidate so check out
that interview guys including Ben
Higgins and Peter Krause we're bringing
some throwback choices in there but if
you were really looking at it yes do you
think especially after last night Blake
Jason you like tell us where your head's
at about who could or should be the
bachelor yeah I said earlier I think
there's a lot of possibilities this year
heading into the bachelor of who could
you know have that lead role I know for
me we obviously have to get through
paradise first but I had such an
unbelievable experience on The
Bachelorette that I would have to see
where I'm at in my life if I'm single if
I'm not and analyze it from there but I
will tell you my experiences with the
bachelor and bachelorette franchise has
been unbelievable I know it can work and
I'm ready to find the love of my life
I'm ready to have a partner I'm ready to
you know have somebody to go do awesome
things with like that's what I want I I
don't want to come my dog's great it's
nice to come home to sniper every night
but I would love to come home to my wife
and have it have a dinner have a glass
of wine and go to bed well I guess we're
gonna see what happens in paradise
Colton we know the tears go down I also
want to ask you about an argument that
comes up between a couple of your
friends Leo and Joe apparently go ahead
to head in paradise would you have ever
seen that coming they both seemed pretty
chill on Bachelorette and then I guess
they go at it a little bit from what
we've seen in the trailer you know I got
to know Leo obviously on our season The
Bachelorette and then I slowly got to
know Joe over paradise it was shocking
because those is sort of out of their
personality but you'll see sort of what
sparked to that whole controversy and
what sparked that that engagement mm-hmm
Leo has also been under
but a fire lately from one miss Becca
Martinez some accusations thrown his way
I don't want to get into that too much
but have you talked to him how is he
doing you know in regards to that I
haven't no yeah bachelor nation there's
just always something going on so if you
were going to kind of tease paradise for
us in a couple of words what do you
think we can expect from the premiere
tonight hot emotional mm-hmm I'm gonna
go a steamy again steamy hot steamy an
emotion it take the hot as like sexy and
the steamy is it's literally so humid
unbelievably hot down there
okay Colton well anything else you can
tell us about your arc on paradise can
you tell us if we'll see you for quite a
bit of time this season I'll say
paradise is full of surprises and it was
an unbelievable experience and that I
will probably be around for a little bit
okay maybe well so you had some emotions
you didn't expect to have yeah
definitely would you say you're happy
with how it turned out yeah I have zero
regrets I like to try to live my life
with no regrets I know that's typically
not possible but you know it's making me
who I am in front of you today so what
can you tell us about how you feel about
Tia today how I felt about tear today I
have the same level of respect and love
for Tia that I always have had okay all
right you guys well bachelor in paradise
premieres tonight on ABC again of course
we just had the Bachelorette finale and
we're gonna have a new interview with
Becca and Garrett
up at et online.com and tonight on the
Entertainment Tonight and cool night
also I just want to find out from you I
know you do this great work with your
legacy foundation what is a way that
people can get involved with that visit
our website Colin's legacy org I'm
actually getting ready to do an awesome
fundraising over Labor Day I am doing
lemonade for legacy and I'm encouraging
kids around the us to do lemonade stands
and compete against each other and see
who could raise the most money for the
Legacy Foundation awesome and that gives
children with cystic fibrosis a fighting
chance yeah right now we're doing a
Legacy Project where I surprise someone
with CF in every single state I'm at six
states right now and we have we have 44
to go so let's do it
all right well Colton is tireless I know
all of you bachelor fans are
tireless especially after a three-hour
finale and then buckle in for two hours
of paradise tonight I'm really excited
for the season of paradise from
everything that I have seen I'm excited
for this year at Paradise yeah I really
am gonna be I think you know last season
we had to get through the scandal and
everything and of course no instance of
wrongdoing was found there but you guys
they talked to Chris Harrison about that
and how he felt about coming back for
season five and getting everybody in a
good place about it and it really seems
like you guys you threw down you had
some fun and some things are gonna go
down this season the most episodes of
paradise ever this season ever and
they're all great okay thank you so much
for watching everyone have a great day
of course check out a new episode of
roses and Rose day it's gonna be up soon
and we will have one recapping the
Paradise premiere up for you tomorrow
bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]